[Música]
y
el director de la organización mundial
de la salud declaró la emergencia
internacional por el brote de la viruela
del mundo el virus ya ha llegado a
decenas de países donde no se habían
reportado casos en la decisión se dio
sin ningún consenso entre el órganos
california vuelve a combatir los
incendios forestales que azotan la
región en pleno verano los servicios de
emergencia continúan luchando con las
llamas del incendio que ya ha consumido
más de 2.600 hectáreas de bosque
una iniciativa en el archipiélago de
galápagos apunta a conservar la riqueza
de su biodiversidad se trata de un
aeropuerto ecológico que recolectará
botellas de plástico que luego serán
convertidas en ropa les contamos cómo es
el proceso
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa por france 24 los saluda andrés
meza puños empezamos con una nueva
emergencia de salud mundial que se da
después del cobi 19 la o ms elevó el más
alto nivel la alerta para la viruela del
mono lo hizo el director de la
organización mundial de la salud pedrosa
ganó nievre 'jesús pese a la oposición
del comité de expertos hasta el momento
se han detectado 16 mil casos en 75
países del mundo y 5 muertes en áfrica
este es un informe de luís muñoz
una emergencia de salud mundial la ms
decretó el nivel más alto de alerta para
la viruela del mono
hemos tenido un brote que se ha
esparcido en el mundo rápidamente con
nuevas formas de transmisión de lo cual
hemos comprendido muy poco la visión del
club he decidido que el brote global de
la viruela del mono representa una
emergencia pública de preocupación
internacional cáncer sin embargo pedrós
decretó la emergencia a pesar de su
comité de expertos nueve miembros de 15
se mostraron en contra tras una reunión
el jueves en ese primer encuentro el 23
de junio los expertos ya habían dicho
que era pronto para la declaración
puesto que podía generar una alarma
excesiva
por su parte para el doctor carlos
álvarez en palabras para france24 es una
forma de mejorar la estrategia
investigando el contagio intensificando
la detección de casos y extendiendo la
vacunación
estas medidas que se toman para permitir
que cada país pues tenga una estrategia
y un plan de trabajo para lograr evitar
que haya una mayor diseminación de esta
epidemia la viruela del mono es una
enfermedad viral que se propaga a través
del contacto cercano causando fiebre
dolor de cabeza de garganta dolores
musculares y lesiones en la piel
genitales o boca hasta el momento se han
registrado 16.000 casos de viruela en 75
países y 5 muertes en áfrica una
virulencia mucho menor que la que tuvo
el commit 19 la última emergencia
sanitaria internacional antes de la
viruela del mono
pasamos a eeuu donde el incendio
forestal aunque en el condado de
mariposa en el estado de california ya
arrasó con miles de hectáreas de bosque
ha obligado a miles de personas a
evacuar y ha desencadenado en cortes del
suministro eléctrico en la zona entre
tanto los bomberos luchan para apagar
las llamas ariana villacorta nos amplia
california arde en llamas el incendio
forestal denominado out en el condado de
mariposa cerca del parque nacional de
yosemite y avanza a gran velocidad ha
destruido al menos 2500 hectáreas de
superficie forestal provocando el cierre
de varias carreteras y más de 6.000
personas están bajo órdenes de
evacuación para ellos la cruz roja tiene
recomendaciones si tienen tiempo es
bueno que empaquen algunos artículos
esenciales medicamentos documentos
importantes ropa extra artículos de aseo
tres temas del momento diez estructuras
residenciales y comerciales han sido
completamente destruidas por el fuego
otras cinco quedaron dañadas y unas dos
mil están bajo amenaza según el
departamento de silvicultura y
protección contra incendios de
california mientras que más de 2.000
hogares y negocios sufrieron cortes del
suministro eléctrico
vinieron hace unos 15-20 minutos y nos
dijeron que todo el mundo tenía que irse
a eso de las 4 se fue la luz del fuego
se ha ido acercando a nosotros cada vez
más rápido
entre tanto más de 400 bomberos junto
con helicópteros aviones y excavadoras
luchan contra el incendio
espero que sean capaces de apagarlo
antes de que dañen las casas de la gente
pero esto no pinta bien
este es el tercer incendio forestal que
el condado de mariposa sufre en dos
semanas estos siniestros se han
agudizado en california en los últimos
años los científicos han dicho que
debido a la crisis climática los
incendios forestales serán cada vez más
frecuentes
destructivos e impredecibles la iglesia
mexicana alza la voz ante la creciente
inseguridad de méxico tras el asesinato
de dos sacerdotes jesuitas en el estado
de chihuahua las autoridades
eclesiásticas han salido de su histórico
silencio y han alzado la voz contra la
política de seguridad del gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador esta
institución suele ser la única que
realiza trabajo de campo en los
territorios más hostiles un equipo de
france 24 viajó al terreno
si quiero activa de monitoreo este botón
de pánico lo necesito porque me muevo en
zonas de riesgo estas medidas
preventivas no evitaron que el padre
filiberto velázquez se enfrentará a los
grupos armados a partir de ahora una
patrulla de la guardia nacional lo
escuchará cuando viaje por la sierra de
guerrero he sido retenido por ellos en
una ocasión por eso fue que
que no puedo estar allá arriba así
sin la seguridad en estas zonas remotas
los narcotraficantes han tomado el
control total hoy el sacerdote se dirige
a san jerónimo una comunidad indígena
donde cinco personas fueron asesinadas
por hombres armados en un pueblo cercano
en 2015 la guerra del narcotráfico con
felipe calderón inició pues todo un
rompimiento de las estructuras
delictivas y empezaron a utilizar
diferentes estrategias para mantener el
control de las zonas y una de eso fue
armar a los indígenas los habitantes de
san jerónimo viven ahora con miedo a los
secuestros y los constantes ataques a
través de grupos de discusión todos
comparten sus experiencias sobre estos
problemas actuales y mataron a mi padre
en 2015 y cuatro años después mataron a
mi madre que buscaba justicia para él
además de décadas de impunidad la actual
política de seguridad bajo el lema
abrazos no balas también es mencionada
por el sacerdote antes y escalada de
violencia como la que está en mexico ese
eslogan se ve rebasado con más de
120.000 homicidios el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador es ya el más
mortífero de mexico la advertencia de la
iglesia sobre la gravedad de la
situación podría tener consecuencias
políticas en otras noticias de mexico un
grupo de artistas rindió homenaje a
víctimas de desaparición en el país en
un colorido mural quedaron grabados los
rostros de personas que han sufrido este
flagelo en territorio mexicano el
objetivo es crear conciencia sobre esta
problemática llamar la atención de las
autoridades y denunciar su falta de
acción se estima que más de 100 mil
personas han desaparecido desde 2006
cuando el gobierno declaró una guerra
contra los cárteles de la droga
y ecuador se convierte en el primer país
del mundo en tener un aeropuerto
ecológico en las islas de galápago fue
lanzado un proyecto que convertirá
botellas de plástico en ropa con el fin
de solucionar una de las amenazas más
grandes para el archipiélago la
abundancia de residuos veamos el informe
galápago es la apuesta a la conservación
de su biodiversidad el aeropuerto de
baltra en el archipiélago de galápagos
se convierte en el primer aeropuerto
ecológico del mundo mediante una
iniciativa hecha por empresas privadas
más de 36 mil botellas de plástico al
año serán convertidas en ropa nos
comprometemos a hacer el retiro el
reciclaje el retiro y el traslado de
todos estos desechos hacia continente
específicamente hacia la ciudad de quito
en el ecuador obviamente las botellas
que llevan los visitantes son
recolectadas en el aeropuerto y enviadas
al continente a mil kilómetros de
distancia
allí son procesadas y convertidas en
tela esto con el fin de mitigar una de
las principales amenazas para el
archipiélago la generación de residuos y
la abundancia de plástico sin embargo se
estima que el 83 por ciento de la basura
que llega a las islas llega de otros
países mediante las corrientes del mar
el proyecto también busca ayudar a
madres solteras la confeccionista con la
que nosotros estamos trabajando ellos le
compran la tela que es procesada a una
fundación de mujeres solteras en quietud
ellas ellas se encargan de recibir el el
plástico y lo ponen en el procesamiento
que las también conocidas como las islas
encantadas fueron declaradas como el
primer patrimonio natural de la
humanidad por la unesco en 1978 su fauna
y su flora son únicas la mayoría de
especies que allí habitan sólo se
encuentran en este lugar del mundo y son
el medio de supervivencia para muchas
otras en el mar
finalizamos en puerto rico- que este fin
de semana conmemora los 500 años de la
fundación de su capital san juan con una
celebración por todo lo alto uno de los
eventos fue una regata en la bahía de la
ciudad de la que participaron decenas de
embarcaciones tanto nacionales como de
países vecinos la fiesta se extenderá
por cuatro días y se espera que unas
30.000 personas asistan a los distintos
eventos
[Música]
de esta manera despedimos este
informativo en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]